[Musik]
kenne diese leute die für ihre statement
videos anfangs von wegen was ich auch
noch drinnen wichtig kamera an machen
ganz neues level an dramatik gefunden
ist dann meistens genau die leute die
damals bei irgendeiner bescheuerten
schule rede da so standen meine damen
und herren ich habe eine rede
vorbereitet aber es kommt einfach jetzt
frei von meinem herzen was ich damit
etwas sagen will meine lieben freunde
ist dass das video hier gar nicht so
ernst und krass sein soll wie es einige
jetzt vielleicht erwarten würden
ich bin dennoch ein bisschen nervös weil
ich irgendwie seit wochen nicht so
richtig hochgeladen habe ich habe mir
sogar heute vom video die zähne geputzt
das mache ich sonst nie also zähne
putzen mache ich generell die allerdings
wird dieses video ist auch kein video wo
ich euch jetzt die tausenden gründe sage
warum in den letzten wochen nichts von
mir kam auf youtube denn das habe ich
mir gedacht mach' ich in einem
live-stream
jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
warum bist du noch damit kann man weiß
dass er doch deutlich weniger da wo wir
jetzt einfach gerade nicht darum die
meisten leute irgendwie zu erreichen ich
habe es über vier millionen abonnenten
auf dem kanal sondern die richtigen und
wichtigen leute zu erreichen und das
sind glaube ich die die auch mein
zweikanal abonniert haben das sind zwar
nur eine halbe million leute aber das
sind halt so die hardcore zuschauer und
die möchte ich erreichen also mir geht
es gar nicht darum jetzt irgendwie
morgen mit einem livestream was weiß ich
wie viele zuschauer zahlen dazu haben
wir viele live läutete damit weisen
sondern wirklich einfach wandert drei
leute zugucken und ich weiß handy
interessiert das wirklich dann bin ich
habe mehr hat wollte ich eigentlich
nichts sagen
schaltet morgen gern einen 19 uhr
youtube.com schrägstrich luke schuh da
bin ich live und da erfahrt ihr alle
gründe warum ich so lange weg war denn
wenn nicht jetzt sagen würde dann wird
das den rahmen sprengen und dieses video
würde wahrscheinlich zwei stunden dauern
das ist so jetzt irgendwie hier
plötzlich wieder vor seiner kamera zu
sitzen
wenn wir da schalte gern morgen 1 19 uhr
youtube.com schrieb sich luca kann jetzt
auch ein